- [Instructor] We're told that a car
with wheel radius r moves
at a linear velocity, v,
and this is a bolded v, to
show that it's a vector.
Suddenly, the car
accelerates to velocity 2v.
How does the angular velocity
of the wheels change?
So pause this video
and see if you can figure
this out on your own.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
So just to visualize what's going on,
let's just draw at least the
front wheel of a car here,
so let me draw the wheel first actually.
So this is the front wheel of the car
and I'll draw the part of the car.
So this is our car right over there.
It might look something like that.
We got the windshield right over there,
so you can visualize this car.
So our car looks something like,
we got our headlights and all the rest.
All right, enough of drawing the car.
So let's imagine this car right over here
has a velocity v, let's
say it's going forward,
so let me draw that.
So its velocity, I'll just
draw it right over here,
it is v.
So this is a velocity of v.
And since it's hard to
hand draw something bolded,
I put a little arrow on it,
but this is equivalent
to this bolded vector v
that you might see
sometimes in your textbook.
Bold would be a vector
or you put an arrow on
it to show it's a vector.
Now I wanna make notation clear.
If we talk about the
magnitude of this vector
and the magnitude of
velocity is just speed,
I'm gonna denote that as
just v without an arrow on it
and not bolded, so this is
going to be the same thing
as the magnitude of our velocity vector,
which is the same thing as our speed.
Now let's take a point on
the outer end of our wheel,
any point on the outer end of the wheel.
Let's say we take this
point right over here
and the center of our
wheel is right over here.
So if the car is moving forward
to the right with velocity v,
what's the velocity of
this point right over here?
Well, the velocity of this point,
it is going to have the same magnitude
but in the opposite direction,
so it's gonna look something like that.
I don't know if those
lines are exactly equal
but these are supposed to
have the same magnitude.
And so you can even imagine this would be,
you could say that this would
be negative v, just like that.
But for the purposes of this question,
I wanna think about its speed.
So the speed here,
the speed here is just
going to be v again.
So the speed of this point,
which is gonna be the same
as the speed of this point,
the direction here is different,
but all of these points along the rim
or along the outside of
the tire, I should say,
are all gonna have the
same speed, speed v.
And we already have a
relationship that we've explored
in previous videos between
speed and angular velocity.
We have seen that the speed,
I'll do it in a new color here.
I'll say v for speed with
no arrow, not bolded,
is going to be equal
to the magnitude of our angular velocity,
so the magnitude of our angular velocity
times our radius.
Times our radius.
Or another way of saying this,
we could say that our speed is equal to,
instead of writing it like this,
let me just write just an
omega without an arrow over it
to say this is the magnitude
of our angular velocity.
So that times our radius.
So here I'm dealing with
all scalar quantities.
I'm saying speed is equal
to magnitude of my angular velocity
times my radius.
So if I wanted angular velocity
as a function of speed,
I could just divide both sides by r.
And so I could say angular velocity
is going to be equal to my speed
over r.
So let's think about what
happens, and let me be clear,
this right over, this distance
right over here, that is r.
That is r right over there.
So if our velocity goes to 2v,
so if this goes from v to,
I'm gonna use a different color,
if that goes from v to 2v,
then this is gonna go from
negative v to negative 2v.
And our speed is gonna go from v
to just 2v, the twice the speed.
And if you have twice the speed,
if this goes by two,
well, then the angular velocity
is going to increase by a factor of two.
So this is going to
increase by a factor of two,
not squaring this or something else.
You're just multiplying
this by one over r.
You're just dividing it by r.
And r is not changing,
just the speed is changing.
And since omega is equal to v over r,
if you double v, you're
gonna double omega.
So how does the angular
velocity of the wheels change?
Well, it's going to double.
It will double.
And we are done.